[Musique]
ici aucune pilule contraceptive sauf
celle d'urgence n'est disponible sans
prescription le Canada aurait tout
intérêt à emboîter le pas aux États-Unis
croix docteur francœur moi je vous
dirais ce que je vois dans mon bureau
comme gynécologue c'est des gens qui
sont incapables d'avoir des rendez-vous
qui sont qui deviennent enceintes parce
qu'elles attardaient pendant des mois
voire des années sur une liste d'attente
pour pouvoir avoir accès à la
contraception mais pour d'autres
professionnels de la santé l'urgence
c'est la gratuité je pense que c'est
surtout là qu'on a un problème en ce
moment au Québec la contraception coûte
cher et ce malgré l'assurance maladie
selon docteur bois le Québec devrait
plutôt s'inspirer de la
Colombie-Britannique qui a rendu gratuit
les contraceptifs sur ordonnance ou
encore l'Ontario et ce qu'on voit de par
exemple les séances de Ontario qui ont
rendu la contraception gratuite leur en
bas de 25 ans c'est que c'est surtout
dans les milieux plus dévalorisés
socio-économiquement où est-ce qu'on a
une augmentation de la prescription de
contraception la pilule loupil devrait
être disponible sans prescription pour
les américaines à compter de 2024 ici
jacauderie Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Montréal